so we came across this video of Cynthia
singing on the street so let's see it
and hear
[Music]
it I'll
be my
drum so good funny girl obviously I love
funny girl so that's the you're I love
that whole musical but what happened
there how did you just start singing
that love you well um he you're just
like you know what I think I in the
middle of the street I bumped into in
the middle of the street and and he
asked me to to sing something I think he
must have heard me sing it one time
before and he was like would you can you
just do a little bit of it can you just
and so I was like okay sure I don't mind
any opportunity where I can make some
music that's what I'm going to do oh I
don't either yeah people always that's
like people come up to me be like oh I
don't know if you want me to talk about
American I'm like hell yeah dude that's
like why I'm here yeah it's also like
this just you're going to care when they
don't want to S that's the thing it's
like I think I think the wonderful thing
about that I knew it would bring him
such joy and he's such a joyous energy
and I want you made his day it was so
awesome and I was having a great time
and people across the street could see
it like it was just fun and you're
reminded right of like why you do it why
you do it how you fell in love with it
yeah those are important
[Music]
moments
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home